for some actors staying in character
even after the director yells Kurtz can
have interesting real-world consequences
when they'd lose themselves inside a
character it can make for some
jaw-dropping performances and some
shocking behind-the-scenes tales
well method acting began as a way to
harness personal experiences and
emotions in order to play a part more
convincingly in recent years it's become
almost synonymous with drastic physical
transformations in one prominent example
Christian Bale made headlines and
jeopardized his health when he lost a
jaw-dropping
63 pounds to play the insomnia played
Trevor Reznik in 2004 so machinist for
weeks before filming began Bale survived
on just an apple and a can of tuna a day
here's a photo of an emaciated Hank
Williams taken three months before the
musicians death as his inspiration you
okay you're any thinner you wouldn't
exist according to co-star Michael
Ironside the drastic diet wasn't even
necessary
the screenwriter for the movie had put
some example weights into the script
based on his own Heights when the much
taller Bale saw the figures he decided
to go for those instead of something
more realistic for his larger frame
Ironside explained those weights he
writes on the bathroom wall in the film
where's actual weights in the film after
filming wrapped Bale bobbed up again
gaining 109 pounds in just six months
for his next role in Batman Begins in
the 1980s Val Kilmer had made something
of a name for himself with his roles in
Top Gun and willow but he hadn't really
had a chance yet to show off his
Juilliard training with a weightier role
that owed change when Kilmer was cast to
play singer Jim Morrison in the 1991
biopic The Doors before he even got the
role the actors spent thousands of
dollars to produce a music video of
himself as Morrison in a bid to impress
director Oliver Stone after landing the
part Kilmer immersed himself in the role
by reading Morrison's writings
interrogating The Doors longtime
producer Paul Rothchild for hours and
spending time in Morrison's old haunts
around Southern California comer learned
to perform 50 songs so well that even
Morrison's bandmates were unable to tell
he was singing when they heard the
recordings except for a handful of
lines and one of Morrison's unearthly
screams Kilmer sank every song in the
film life doing the music was a pleasure
singing live for a live audience and
having them film it was satisfying
he earned widespread praise for the role
but the actor claimed there was nothing
Supernatural about his uncanny
performance explaining it's just a
blessing of acting it's not possession
it's just a reminder of what we all can
do with our minds if we are open and
willing we can do anything by the time
director Kimberly PS secured the funding
to make boys don't cry she had already
spent three years desperately searching
for the perfect person to play transmen
brandon teena
who was sexually assaulted and killed in
1993 after showing up to an audition in
her husband's clothes and convincing a
security guard she was male the
relatively unknown Hilary Swank was cast
as Brandon beating out more than 100
others I strapped impact that's what I
call it strapping my breasts putting a
sock in my pants Swank had to undergo
both a physical and psychological
transformation for the role for weeks
she lived as a trans man both on and off
the set she lost weight to bring out the
angle of a jaw and cheekbones cut a hair
short bound her breasts and packed a
pant with a rolled-up sock she practiced
a lower register of her voice and
immersed herself in Tina's life by
reading court transcripts about Brandon
and books about being transgendered
Swank was frequently able to pass his
mail during this period even fooling her
neighbors at other times as some of the
people she met seemed quote threatened
by her androgynous appearance she
explained I didn't realize what it was
like to be out in the world as someone
that people can't define that's a really
lonely place for swine complain Brandon
was a personally transformative
experience she concluded I was afforded
this amazing opportunity to stretch
myself as an artist and it just happened
to stretch me as a human being the film
certainly transformed Swank's budding
career she went on to win an Oscar and
numerous other accolades for impressive
performance actors are often praised
when they go method for a movie role but
Jared Leto reportedly went a bit
overboard while playing the Joker in
2016 so Suicide Squad he was inspired by
its Joker predecessor Heath Ledger who
famously used method acting while
playing the comic-book villain in 2008
The Dark Knight
however some of the creative choices
Leto made on the Suicide Squad
were quite shocking to say the least to
get into the psychotic character he had
a henchman deliver a videotaped message
and the dead pig to the cast he later
gave co-star Margot Robbie a live rat
I did get thank-you notes for some of
these gifts mind you or what or what
specific gift was thanked everyone on
the shoots called him Joker or smiley or
mr. J he spent hours on YouTube watching
footage of actual violent crimes being
committed even writer director David
Ayer was intimidated explaining you can
feel that when he comes to work the crew
feels it everyone feels it he's
terrifying in the end Suicide Squad and
letõs performance were met with
extremely mixed reviews in an essay for
the Atlantic
Angelica Jade Bastion argued that quote
Hollywood has ruined method acting and
said Jared Leto Stern in Suicide Squad
is the latest reminder that a technique
has become more about ego and marketing
than good performances Sylvester
Stallone approached rocky 4 with all of
the efforts he could muster and the
desire to make the film's brutal boxing
scenes between rocky balboa and soviet
fighter Ivan Drago feel as real as
possible
so naturally Stallone and actor Dolph
Lundgren went at each other with all
they had
Stallone told Ain't It Cool News what
you see in the first 20 seconds is real
and after the third take of taking buddy
blows I felt a burning in my chest but
ignore this later that night I couldn't
breathe very well and they took me to
the emergency room after registering an
extremely elevated blood pressure
Stallone was airlifted to another
hospital May he spent eight days in
intensive care
apparently longer and had hit him in the
chest with such force the Stallone's
heart quote slammed against his breast
bone and began to swell and without
medical intervention it may have stopped
completely but at least a fight between
Rocky and Drago looks cool it would have
guessed that Shia LaBeouf shaggy-headed
child star of holes and even Stevens
would grow up to become one of his
generations most boundary-pushing actors
forever grappling with the psychological
ramifications of being an actor and the
nature of Fame LaBeouf takes his work
seriously Syd spirits religious
spirituals transcending and he went
all-in
mind body and soul when preparing for
his role as devoutly religious tank
gunner boy bible swan in
AAA's World War - military film a fury
the actor told dazed David told us right
from the gates I need you to give me
everything so the day after I got the
job I joined the US National Guard he
spent weeks living on a base and he
served as chaplains assistant that's
helped LaBeouf wrap his head around the
characters faith as dedicating himself
baptized an event he commemorated with a
tattoo of a cross for the more physical
part of the life of a long-serving
soldier LaBeouf made himself extremely
uncomfortable saying I poured my two
thousand life to my face up I didn't
bathe for four months previously known
as a comic actor for his work in such
broad Farrah's and Living Colour and
booty call actor Jamie Foxx gave a
revelatory performance a soul legend and
musical innovator Ray Charles in the
2004 biopic Ray in order to play a man
so iconic that he was nicknamed the
genius folks had to take the
transformative route in his preparation
first the usually fit folks lost 30
pounds to play the slighted Charles Fox
fasted for a week then worked out daily
while following a restrictive diet that
in order to relate to how Charles he was
blind interacted with the world Raider
actor Taylor Hackford requested that Fox
seal his eyes closed the actor said okay
and he was fitted with prosthetics at
mimic Charles and pet eyelets
not only could Fox not see at all but it
took him two weeks to get acclimated to
the world of darkness which left him
feeling claustrophobic and suffering
from panic attacks Fox told the New York
Times imagine having your eyes glued
shut for 14 hours a day be that as it
may portraying Ray Charles one Fox an
Academy Award Tom Hanks hasn't been shy
about dramatically changing his body for
a film role he puts on 30 pounds to play
south soccer baseball coach Jimmy Dugan
in a league of their own and then he
lost a couple dozen pounds to play
hiv-positive lawyer Andrew Beckett in
Philadelphia but the 2000 drama castaway
required his most audacious body morph
to date directed by Robert Zemeckis
castaway tells the story of Chuck Noland
a FedEx employee from Memphis who after
a plane crash finds himself stranded on
an island for years struggling to
survive with very little food at the
ready at the beginning of the film Chuck
is slightly overweight and then he
wastes away during as tropical isolation
that's something that couldn't or
wouldn't be faked
Hanks lost over 50 pounds to play Chuck
and castaway shot around hang
his rigorous weight-loss plan so mecca's
film the first part of the movie then
shut the production for a year in order
for hanks to lose the way to grow a
beard and develop a deep island style
tan Hanks was rewarded for his efforts
by his peers as he was seasoned Academy
Award nomination for castaway but he
believes the weight fluctuations
contributed to his developing type 2
diabetes when it came time to prepare
for his role in Dallas buyers club as a
hiv-positive Ron Woodroof Matthew
McConaughey sought out the wisdom of a
master to find out how to lose weight to
portray an emaciated character Tom Hanks
McConaughey told people by actually
called Tom and had a great conversation
with him about what he learned about
losing weight for Philadelphia and
castaway he took some of that advice
along with the assistance of a
nutritionist and shrunk from 185 pounds
during right past his goal of 145 and
landing at 135 5 ounces of fish a cup of
vegetables twice a day I'm putting in
the morning and as much red wine as I
liked at night
McConaughey told Radio Times that around
that time he started losing his eyesight
his character had to be pale so the
actor also refrained from going outside
for six months more rapid weight loss
and sunlight deprivation may weaken the
body McConaughey explained that the
energy moves somewhere else saying all
the acuity energy and power
I lost from the neck down transferred to
the neck up he might be right because he
won an Oscar for Dallas buyers club
Darren Aronofsky's 2010 movie Black Swan
is an absolutely harrowing psychological
drama set in the high stakes highly
competitive world of professional ballet
Natalie Portman plays dancer Nina Sayers
whose mine slowly unravels while
preparing to play the pivotal role of
the Swan queen in a production of the
classic Tchaikovsky ballet Swan Lake top
level dance is as hard on the body as
Swan Lake was for Nina sayers sanity and
Portman was fully committed to doing
whatever it took to flesh out a
character the already slight twist lost
20 pounds to play a ballerina sticking
to a diet of primarily carrots and
almonds that didn't provide much fuel
for the eight hours of ballet training
and prep for money or daily in
pre-production the actress told
Entertainment Weekly
there was sunlight so I thought I
literally was going to die it was the
first time I understood how you could
get so wrapped up in a role that it
could sort of take you down Poorman
starves herself put our body through
ballet boo
and dislocated a rib for Black Swan but
it may have been worth it she won the
Academy Award for a performance check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos but your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]